we did
masks social distancing what did we
learn
to prepare for the next one airports
travel you said something early about
influenza that you don't need airplanes
to
have a virus you can do it through birds
so just maybe talk from your standpoint
of preparing for the next one
well again i think the same lessons that
came out of 19
are confirmed by this one number one
tell the truth to get your public the
public on your side
certainly don't divide the public tell
the truth
keep a consistent message have a
credible spokesperson that's all sort of
the same
thing number two these so-called
non-pharmaceutical interventions work
they work better than any of us ever
imagined
you know i supported them but based on
the 1918
experience i was kind of skeptical
skeptical about how well they would work
but we have learned
much to the amazement of the public
health community
that if you do it right you can contain
even a disease as transmissible as this
one and this is
more transmissible than influenza you
know i i cited
uh you know australia a few minutes ago
they have fewer than a thousand deaths
and out of 25 million people that would
be the equivalent to 13
000 deaths in the united states taiwan
hasn't had a case of influenza since of
covet 19 since april 13th
you can do it right we didn't
it's that simple but those are the
lessons that it is controllable the
other thing is the technology we
you know because the bush administration
really started this massive
program to prepare for pandemic they
expected it to be
influenza but it applied to any
respiratory disease
part of that was creating
putting money into basic scientific
research on vaccines
and as a result that's why we were able
to get the vaccine so quickly
there was an infrastructure there was a
platform
of how to make a vaccine that
could be applied to basically any virus
and they just plugged in the genetic
code for the
spike protein into this platform that
already existed
that had been developed
you know hopefully in the future we'd be
able to do it again but not every virus
is
as susceptible to a vaccine you know
we've been working on a vaccine for hiv
for you know 35 years and we haven't
gotten there yet
same thing for influenza we've been
looking working on a vaccine for
influenza we have vaccines but they're
not nearly as effective as the one
against covet 19.
so improving the basic science getting
uh investing in basic science investing
in the public health
infrastructure that's one of the reasons
why the vaccine rollout
is so screwed up is because there is
essentially no
public health infrastructure again
another basic scientific
investment in broad-spectrum anti-viral
drugs
we originally thought that we would have
drugs that worked against cobit 19
before we got a vaccine
we really don't have any effective drugs
yet
except for dexamethasone which which
helps significantly
but that's a long way from a magic
bullet investing in that area of
research
you know further investments vaccine and
public health infrastructure
and telling the truth i think those are
the
the main lessons that and maybe
throw in one other thing and that's
surveillance for new viruses
uh you know the biggest concern had
always been an influenza pandemic like
1918.
the world health organization
did create a worldwide surveillance
system
looking for new influenza viruses
so the alert alerted very early in the
process
you know that needs to be expanded
and again countries have to tell the
truth china
did not tell the truth in sars they
improved a lot
when we were concerned about bird flu
they did not tell the truth in covet 19.
and they're still hiding it you know
just i think it was
yesterday they're still negotiating
earlier they had agreed to allow who
investigating team into the country to
try to track down the source of
covet 19. and yesterday
turns out they're not letting that team
in yeah quote negotiating
unquote over what they're going to do so
they're still not willing to tell the
truth in china
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye